the aorta is the largest artery in your
body your heart pumps fresh oxygen-rich
blood through your aorta to deliver
oxygen and nutrients to all your organs
and tissues
your aorta is divided into two main
sections the thoracic aorta and the
abdominal aorta the thoracic aorta has
four parts the aortic root ascending
aorta aortic arch and descending aorta
the wall of your aorta is composed of
three layers that give it strength the
intima or inner layer the media or
middle layer and the adventitia or outer
layer
the elastic muscular media prevents your
blood pressure from rupturing the wall
over time degenerative disease may cause
the media layer to break down weakening
the wall of your aorta blood pumping
against the weakened area may cause it
to bulge outward like a balloon
when this condition occurs in your chest
it is called a thoracic aortic aneurysm
these aneurysms may occur in one of
several places including the aortic root
the ascending aorta or the descending
aorta
most thoracic aneurysms have no symptoms
however when they reach larger sizes
various symptoms may appear depending on
the severity and location of the
aneurysm symptoms of stable thoracic
aneurysms may include shortness of
breath chest back or abdominal pain
difficulty swallowing and hoarseness if
the aneurysm ruptures or dissect more
dramatic symptoms will appear including
a ripping sensation in the chest severe
pain in the back between the shoulder
blades dizziness and difficulty walking
and speaking if you have these symptoms
you should seek immediate medical
attention as this condition is
life-threatening
blood pumping against weakened aortic
walls can lead to another
life-threatening condition called aortic
dissection which may or may not occur
within an aneurysm
most commonly a aortic dissection begins
with damage to the intima later blood
moves through the break in the intima
separating it from the media causing
bleeding inside the wall of your aorta
as a result a flap called a septum forms
between the true aortic channel and the
false channel
from here the blood may break through
the outer layer of the aortic wall
causing an immediate life-threatening
condition or it may reenter the aorta
through another tear in the intima
overtime a blood clot may form in the
false channel
an aortic dissection may be classified
according to its location and duration
of symptoms
in the Stanford system if you have an
aortic dissection in your ascending
aorta it is called a type-a dissection
all other dissections are called type B
the most common symptom of thoracic
aortic dissection is sharp or stabbing
chest pain usually sudden and severe if
you have a type-a dissection you're most
likely to feel pain in your chest if you
have a type B dissection you're more
likely to feel pain in your back than
your chest if you have these symptoms
you should seek immediate medical
attention as this condition can be
life-threatening